CASSIE KOZYRKOV: With over
300 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't
leverage on the cloud
to transform your
business, then stay tuned
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Machine learning is an
algorithmic approach
to making repeated
decisions with data.
So check that you have all those
components before you begin--
data to learn from, check;
access to machine-learning
algorithms, check; desire to
automate repeated decisions--
and we're really
talking repetition here,
not 10 decisions, but more
like 10,000 or 10 billion--
check.
Great.
Let's dive in and summarize
the big ideas from the talk.
First, ML can be used to solve
many problems for which you're
writing rules today.
In fact, a great way to find
opportunities to apply it
is to look for rules
in your business.
For example, query
completion in Google Search
used to be a real tangle
of handcrafted rules.
Applying machine learning to
it brought our biggest boost
in ranking quality
in over two years.
Secondly, machine
learning is how you
personalize your applications.
Because ML scales better
than those handcrafted rules
and it lets you layer models
on top of your existing logic,
you can now also delight folks
who are unlike your main user
contingent.
Now, of course, what makes
all this tick is data.
You can think of ML as turning
that rules-based process
on its head.
Instead of starting
with the model or rules,
flip it to start with your data.
Thirdly, design systems
with the expectation
that you will have more,
more, more data next year.
Your world isn't static,
and you should expect
that your data will grow.
And this is a great thing
because more data wins.
But what happens
when this puts you
in the realm of
exabytes or petabytes?
For example, deep
learning only works well
with large data sets.
To drop your error
rate linearly,
you're going to have to increase
your data exponentially.
That's a log scale over there.
I like predictions.
If you're into deep
learning, I predict
lots of data in your future.
So here's a suggestion.
Don't spend all
your personal time
on big-data infrastructure.
Instead, take a
serverless approach
so you can put your effort
into what actually brings you
the most value.
Think in terms of code,
not infrastructure, which
brings us to our fourth idea.
Use a platform that lets you
forget about infrastructure
and offers great
prebuilt models.
Look for flexibility for
different ML Scenarios.
So let's revisit deep learning.
The compute power needed to
do state of the art machine
learning went up 10 million
times in the last six years--
10 million times, whoa.
If you want to be
on the cutting edge,
you're going to need an
efficient, cost-effective ML
environment.
To handle more and
more data, you're
going to need to go distributed.
To handle more and
more compute, you're
going to need better hardware.
Google Cloud brings you
the ideal environment
for distributed
processing on hardware
tailored to your needs.
It gives you a fantastic,
fully managed, serverless way
to run ML with great
prebuilt models,
so you don't need to build
everything from scratch
if you don't want to.
I mean, why reinvent wheels you
don't have to reinvent, right?
In summarizing
this talk for you,
I left out the
colorful use cases
that really bring
those ideas to life.
Meet machine learning from
movie recommender systems, fraud
detection, customer service,
the internet of things,
car auctions, gaming, and more.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link
in the description
below, and don't forget to
subscribe to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]